Kennan alpaca help protect the shores of
the Gulf of Mexico from a massive oil
slick they're not having a great time
but by the time they're finished they're
gonna feel a lot for some Gulf Coast
residents are pinning hopes on what may
be a unique defense against millions of
gallons of oil that is spewed from a
ruptured deep-sea drill site so get up
with hair skip a few days of shampooing
and human hair can get oily the link
between hair and oil has led salons and
pet groomers to save hair to make what
as hope will essentially be giant oil
absorbers hair can be hard to get in
high volumes quickly that's where these
four alpacas at the Alabama Gulf Coast
zoo and several other animal species can
lend a hand or hoof these animals have a
lot of fleece and matter of trust the
group which is one of the coordinators
of the so called hair boom Drive says
alpaca fleece is great material and the
zoo is happy to oblige
we received contributions from people
all over the world and this is our way
of trying to give back and say thank you
for what you've done for us Paul says
the haircut is good for the animals
given the hot and humid weather many
Gulf Coast residents are pooling
together as the oil slick spreads the
heavy flow since bps Deepwater Horizon
oil rig burned and sank April 22nd has
produced one of the biggest spills in
history those scientists are not sure
the booms offer a practical defense
against the oil some think it's worth a
try University of South Alabama
biologist David Nelson says alpaca
fleece looks likely to absorb oil well
the alpaca fleece is a fine kind of hair
it's the kind that's close to the body
and it's it's very cotton like and
because of that is very small and it
absorb a great deal of the oil but the
timing is important Nelson says hair
booms wouldn't work once the oil starts
evaporating and becomes thicker well it
would work if you had a a very liquid
form of the petroleum if it were a gunky
if it were forming tar balls which it
does in time that would not adhere to
the hair not far from the University
volunteers
stuffed pantyhose with the fleece human
hair clippings and fur from pets they
slide donated hose over PVC pipes and
then stuffed the fleece down into the
hose finally they tie it off and stack
them up it's a renewable resource and
it's just something that we can do on
our own it's unclear how much good the
hair booms may do and cleanup officials
from the federal government and BP have
not approved the method but scientists
are eagerly watching for the outcome
you